what is happening there reject nation
greg and john
here quick scoop of the morning
basically we met up at 5 30 in the
morning thought change heat trailer was
coming out at 6 00 a.m
it did it people were saying it's not
coming out for a few weeks
so we ended up shooting a breakdown
reaction to
the article that came out on
entertainment weekly shot for like 35
minutes
after the trailer did come out we shot a
reaction for it i was like all right let
me just edit the entertainment weekly
one
mike actually wasn't plugged all the way
in there's no audio
i was like oh great so with that in mind
paul from heavy spoilers i talked with
him a few months back about possibly
covering one of his videos one of these
days and he's
absolutely fine with it so i was like
well change of plans
let's check out the shang chi trailer
breakdown characters explain easter eggs
and things you missed from
heavy spoilers if you guys have not
subscribed to happy spoilers
do it he is killing it on youtube as of
late to put it
lightly guy goes trending like every
freaking week
so he'll be at a million subscribers
soon enough anywho let's see what he's
got to say
educate us man
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and huge happy birthday
to see moo lee who is likely celebrating
with him
he might have mispronounced it we might
have mispronounced he's the first asian
superhero to head up
right sorry scarlett johansson the
trailer is incredible and throughout
this video we're going to be discussing
some of its characters
the easter eggs things you missed and
everything you need to know about it
if you enjoyed the video then please
smash your thumbs up and make sure you
subscribe for content like this each and
every day
we are currently covering falcon in the
winter soldier and you definitely don't
want to miss our breakdown on the finale
coming this friday
so make sure you get it locked in yeah
now without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of shang chi and
the legend of the ten rings
okay so the ten rings are an
organization that you will likely
remember from the first iron man movie
the terrorist organization was hired by
opening by train to kidnap tony stark
and he pretty much put him on the path
to become iron man iron man 3 starred
guy
pierce's aldrich killian who was posing
as their lead of the mandarin
and the marvel one shot that accompanied
that film showed the actor trevor being
confronted by one of their members in
prison
i bet we will see trevor slattery maybe
early on in this movie and i imagine
he'll either be tortured
imprisoned or killed like that on a pike
yeah
very early on or it would be kind of
cool too actually
punishment yeah man darker marvel the
actor trevor being confronted by one of
their members in
prison kylian taking on the moniker
caused a lot of controversy
and kevin feige has stated that they're
writing that wrong by having the real
mandarin appearing in this film
yay now the movie itself is apparently
going to show the criminal
empire that he has amassed over the
years this film is actually set to show
events that happen between the snap in
the blip
as well as the aftermath of it bringing
us fully up to speed with the mc
cool if you cast your mind back to
endgame you'll remember that there was a
big bit with hawkeye in which he was
taking down mobsters in tokyo
yeah this arc is apparently going to be
expanded on and we will follow
certain members oh really things as they
say origins of the haircut
society though we might not see things
from hawkeye's perspective
we could see these mobsters potentially
popping up in the movie
explaining certain parts in endgame it's
all connected
now as for the mandarin the film is
gonna be making him not only the leader
of the ten rings but also the father of
shang qi
this differs quite a lot from the comic
books as in those it was
fu manchu who was his dad however marvel
came out and said that because
he played on a lot of stereotypes that
he's a bit of a problematic character
unless they've decided to come by about
the mandarin and fu manchu
into well them android i talked about
this a little bit in the reaction i'm
loving the fact of how personal it's
automatically going to be from the fact
that this is
his father essentially the mcu has dealt
so much with parental figures before and
then you had guardians of the galaxy 2
which had ego
the villain of the movie is the main
character's father but this will be
much more direct where it seems like
right from the offset we know he's the
bad guy
oh you know what i mean well we're gonna
see him probably throughout various
stages of shanxi's life too because of
all like i love that the trailer showed
us so many different
ages along the way of the training and
the relationship like it looks like yeah
we've had some dads in the
mcu that are prominent characters but it
looks like we're going to actually
explore the relationship
and it is smart to not include foo
manchu it's absolutely smart
asian representation all the way panoy
pride in the house
caucasian pride in the house sure this
is something similar to what they did
with whiplash
who was a combination of crimson dynamo
and
well whiplash now there's there's
actually a big article on wikipedia that
talks about the controversy that
fumanchi was caused over the years
such as his nonsensical name the fact
he's basically just a stereotype
and also that he said in a book once
kill the white man and take his woman
so yeah jesus
stereotypes and that the mandarin will
be the character to do this
so yeah fu manchu uh he's but he's about
as popular as army hammer is at a vegan
meet up
and thus
mcu he's been trained by his father in
the ways of martial arts since he was a
child
and the character has very much seen the
ins and outs of the criminal
organization
in the source material they never out
and out said what his powers and
abilities are
and depending on what you read very much
but he can clone himself
though he has possessed superhuman
abilities from time to time
on the whole shang chi tends to just be
a normal person
with a very certain set of skills
because of this shang chi
is a next level athlete that's often
referred to as the greatest
empty-handed fight error in the marvel
universe move over iron fist just stupid
jump get
get the hell out of here ashanti has
mastered
and because of this he's able to push
his body beyond the usual limitations
that normal people face
he could basically do a trailer
breakdown 20 minutes after the trailer
releases
which is almost as fast as me
being able to tap into this energy force
means that he has a heightened sense of
awareness to everything around him
i don't think i'm spoiling anything here
by saying that the film will pretty much
revolve around him going toe-to-toe with
his father
and he will likely wrestle with whether
to keep it in the family like stephen
sharon carter
or become his own man that fights for
truth and justice
spoiler alert it's probably the latter
he's also going to be joined
but they did say i believe not long ago
one it might have been the director who
came out
i can't remember who it would include
his ability to clone himself kind of
like naruto's shadow clowns he'd only be
able to use it minimally during some
fight scenes actually which would be
really cool to see brought to life i
didn't see any of that in the trailer
it's supposed to be in the movie
i i saw it all over the yeah man
no yeah that would be super cool to see
he's also going to be joined by his
estranged sister xiao ling who will also
be the mandarin's daughter
spoiler alert again now i kind of feel
that if the mandarin gets taken down in
this film
that she might step into his shoes and
could end up becoming the villain in any
future films
some people were speculating that the
aquafina might have been the
sister character follow sui but probably
just a friend katie ares has said that
shanghi is one of the only people on
earth that could stand toe-to-toe with
the god
and though he probably won't be facing
off against them we do know that bing
fan boom
will be in the film and that this super
villain will probably cause a lot of
issues for sure
it's going to be interesting to see how
they pull this off but i kind of feel
that they're going to weave this in as a
challenge for shangchi to take on
in the comics however he is a big super
villain so they might even have it all
connected to the ten rings
and this could come as a big shock to
shanxi who discovers that his father is
in league with the master
that might lead to him uncovering the
truth but again all fan theories at the
moment
the funko pops for the characters show
that he's called
who knows he is the next big character
i thought it was just a rumor that thing
fang fung would be in this i didn't know
it was actually confirmed that was toy
leaks man
also iron man villain i i did hear that
there is
if you watch iron man 1 there's there is
a billboard that has fing fang boom on
it
i never saw it but maybe if i googled it
right now and included in this video
then here it is the next big character
we need to discuss is katie
who according to the wiki is shangchi's
friend
friend being in quotation marks i'm
guessing now according to interviews
she's going to be thrust into a world
where she doesn't really know what to do
and at the same time she'll be
discovering things about herself
you also have gia lee as well as razor
fist
razors that has no superpowers
but like he has quite a high level of
stamina and strength
after honing his body to perfection he
decided to take the next logical step
and replace his hand with a blade makes
sense now in the comics
there's been three versions of the
character with some cutting off both
hands whilst others just did the one
makes it a nightmare when you have a
girlfriend if you do both
so this version is just gonna have the
one and there's also going to be ronnie
chang as john john
and michelle yo as giannan she's
previously featured in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2.
a lot of things with actors playing
different people so i
totally forgot about those things
you know that he's had a good time
during this but now he's being called
back to do his family duties
we see him as a valet and also hanging
out with some friends taking selfies you
know
just that's right yeah now 10 is an
important number as he was also trained
for 10 years as a boy
which we see in the first look this
training chronicles him growing up
and it's clear he was put through his
paces in order to be the best
it's here we're introduced to death
dealer as well who is one of his
father's closest allies
shang chi is definitely going to be
going head-to-head with him at several
points
as he tries to take his death down yeah
and expect some amazing fight sets with
this character
now this training was put in place so
that the most dangerous people in the
world
wouldn't be able to kill him being the
son of the head of a criminal empire
obviously makes him a target
and the mandarin was likely worried that
he might be captured and used for ransom
this could explain why we see him doing
low-level jobs throughout the trailer
as they might have been put in place for
him to keep a low profile
they're reenacting the key and peel
sketch yeah where they're gonna
bring it or go through all this marvel
hey man yeah man that mandarin stoke
that mandarin stuff they had trouble
sliding in the movie and it wasn't the
man
after all it wasn't the man it wasn't
the man they got the man it wasn't the
real mandarin stuff it's here that we
also get a close look at taser face
so sorry razorfest yeah now it looks
like there's also going to be some
supernatural elements in the film such
as some giant beasts
and sideways water that's that's a
scientific term
now the film seems to be very steeped in
the elements and there could be people
who can control water
it seems like the mandarin is almost the
one doing it at one point
as he opens up a vault making me think
that he is perhaps the one doing it
that might be wrong but with so many
changes to the source material
you just don't know now we get a closer
look at the beasts later on
and i'm guessing just in the same way
that rhinos were used in black panther
now this will happen with them and also
the winged creatures
at one point we see that the mandarin
has ten rings around his wrist
five on each side and these power up in
the trailer
there's a bit where someone is using
something similar to destroy a table
i'm guessing that this is the mandarin
possessing superhuman abilities at this
point
there's also an intro well i thought
yeah i thought that was from the
flashback earlier when you see him
walking with young
shang chi right yeah it looks like the
reverse of that shot or whatever
it looks like a business he came in to
do there's also an interesting part in
which he fights his sister
in what seems to be a tournament shang
chi was very much the favorite
and there she's had to go off and crash
great
this is why i think that she will take
the mantle at some point and this fight
definitely sets up their rivalry now
speaking of razor fist
shang chi fights him on a bus at one
point and we really see how good
the martial art is gonna be in this
movie it looks incredible and i love the
fight scenes on display here
there's also a shot of ancient times
potentially showing a battle that
happened centuries ago
involving the ten rings i might be
digging two during the blip
the makes him seem like he's dressed in
ancient attire
the character might even be immortal in
this movie
and we could see his very first battle i
love the frame with the rings behind him
organization that's existed over the
millennia so if he lives forever
then it does make a lot of sense why
he's managed to keep control
as mentioned earlier shang chi is
someone that can take on superpowered
beings
and therefore having his dad have
certain abilities it just
just makes the stakes higher it's even
possible that the ten rings themselves
grant superhuman abilities
and this is where the legend of the ten
rings comes from to
captain obvious now they seem like a
macguffin similar to the infinity stones
and the mandarin wearing them clearly
having advanced abilities
it all just makes sense i am wondering
if they're going to simplify the 10
rings down a little bit
not give each of them their own specific
power and and
force they're all so specific and it
might be a little too much
yeah everything in this trailer at least
suggests that they're some kind of
power conduit that i'll need to be
working together in some variety exactly
but you never know yeah i mean i can
imagine them wanting to differentiate
from the infinity stones specifically
but i wouldn't be surprised if maybe
they come up with some alternate
mythology of like when they're all
working together it's this way but
even just one of them is powerful in
this way yeah because in the comics it's
like alien technology where you got it
from and that links to fing fang films
but
all right we'll see we'll see the
trailer ends with a bus crash scene
that's very similar to speed with
the sandra bullock s character doing the
driving well
she busts up the bad guys it's a great
way to end it and i can't wait to see it
and i know she's not called this sandra
bullock trailer
yeah i know i know exactly who she is
anyway
now as for my daughter that sounds like
an improvised joke
trailer is actually starting to really
shed light on different cultures
and if they can pull it off with black
panther i'm sure they can do it with
this too
i really want to see some cool martial
arts in this movie and it looks like it
could be something
really really special though i'm not too
well versed in the shanghai mythos
i did the reason she came in that's
right
after a year of delays that we're
getting all this content coming thick
and fast
hell yeah i really really liked it and
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer
if there's anything i missed let me know
if there's a character you think is
going to be bigger
let me know and if you just hated my
accent and pronunciation
then let me know as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe the notifications
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the trailer good job man winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers there's something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of madame hydra which
is going to be linked on screen right
now
the character watching falcon in the
winter soldier
so it's definitely worth watching if you
have any questions about it
that out of the way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
poor let's see you next time see ya take
care
peace oh thanks paul rumor is mordo
might be in it too
omega red spiral whiz kid there's a
whole bunch of characters that are
expected to be in here during that
tournament
every knee marvel movies does this open
up the door for mutants
maybe in the tournament we'll get a
declared mutant character
which would be really awesome anyway
this is a great breakdown
really loved it thank you for putting it
together guys subscribe to heavy
spoilers if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
catch you guys soon